Nous devons reconnaître et prendre au sérieux ces divisions.
Plus profondément, le vote nous apprend quelque chose
concernant la politique d'aujourd'hui.
La politique contemporaine n'est pas restreinte à la droite et la gauche.
Il n'est pas juste question de taxes et de dépenses.
Il est question de mondialisation.
La fracture dans la politique contemporaine
se trouve entre ceux qui embrassent la mondialisation
et ceux qui la craignent.
(Applaudissements)
En regardant pourquoi ceux qui voulaient partir --
appelés les « Partants », opposés aux « Restants » --
les sondages montrent deux facteurs
qui ont de l'importance.
Le premier est l'immigration et le second la souveraineté.
Ils représentent le désir des gens de reprendre le contrôle de leur vie
et le sentiment de ne pas être représentés par les politiques.
Mais ces idées sont signe de peur et d'aliénation.
Elles représentent une retraite vers le nationalisme et les frontières
que nombre d'entre nous rejetteraient.
Ce que je veux suggérer c'est que la situation est plus complexe,
les internationalistes libéraux
comme moi, je m'inclus fermement dans cette catégorie,
devons nous réintégrer à la situation
afin de comprendre comment nous sommes arrivés là.
En regardant les schémas de vote à travers le Royaume-Uni,
nous voyons clairement les divisions.
En bleu ceux qui voulaient rester
et en rouge ceux qui voulaient partir.
En regardant cela,
ce qui m'a personnellement touché était que j'avais passé très peu de temps
dans les zones en rouge.
En regardant les 50 premières zones du Royaume-Uni
avec le taux de départ le plus élevé,
j'ai réalisé avoir passé en tout 4 jours de ma vie dans ces endroits.
Dans certains de ces lieux,
je ne connaissais même pas le nom des circonscriptions.
Cela fut un choc pour moi
et cela suggérait que les gens comme moi,
qui se considèrent inclusifs, ouverts et tolérants,
ne connaissent peut-être pas leurs pays et sociétés
aussi bien qu'ils l'aimeraient.
(Applaudissements)
Le défi qui en découlait était le besoin de trouver une nouvelle façon
de narrer la mondialisation à ces personnes,
de reconnaître que pour ces gens n'ayant pas toujours accès à l'université,
n'ayant pas toujours grandi avec internet,
n'ayant pas l'opportunité de voyager,
ils peuvent ne pas être convaincus par le discours qui nous convainc
dans nos bulles souvent libérales.
(Applaudissements)
Nous devons nous adresser à plus de monde et comprendre.
Dans le vote de départ, une minorité a colporté la peur et la haine,
créant des mensonges et la méfiance
autour de, par exemple, l'idée que le vote pour l'Europe
pourrait réduire le nombre de réfugiés et de demandeurs d'asile en Europe,
alors que le vote de départ n'avait rien à voir avec l'immigration
venant de l'extérieur de l'Union Européenne.
Mais pour une grande majorité des Partants,
le problème était la désillusion envers l'establishment politique.
Pour beaucoup, c'était une protestation,
le sentiment que personne ne les représentait,
qu'ils ne pouvaient trouver un parti politique parlant en leur nom
et ils ont donc rejeté l'establishment politique.
Cela est vrai ailleurs en Europe et dans la majorité du monde démocratique.
Nous le voyons avec l'augmentation de la popularité
de Donald Trump aux États-Unis,
la montée de popularité de Viktor Orbán en Hongrie,
la montée de popularité de Marine Le Pen en France.
Le spectre du Brexit est dans toutes nos sociétés.
Je pense que nous devons nous poser ma seconde question :
comment devrions-nous répondre ?
Pour nous tous qui voulons
créer des sociétés libérales, ouvertes, tolérantes,
nous avons urgemment besoin d'une nouvelle vision,
une vision d'une mondialisation plus tolérante et inclusive,
qui entraîne les gens avec nous au lieu de les laisser derrière.
Cette vision de la mondialisation
doit commencer par la reconnaissance des avantages de la mondialisation.
Le consensus parmi les économistes
est que le libre-échange, le mouvement de capital,
le mouvement de personnes entre les pays
bénéficient globalement à tous.
Pour les responsables des relations internationales,
la mondialisation apporte de l'interdépendance,
ce qui entraîne coopération et paix.
Mais la mondialisation a également des effets de redistribution.
Elle crée des gagnants et des perdants.
Pour prendre l'exemple de la migration,
nous savons que l'immigration est positive pour l'économie globale
sous n'importe quelles conditions.
Mais nous devons aussi être conscients
qu'il y a des conséquences en redistribution,
qu'une migration importante de personnes peu qualifiées
peut faire baisser les salaires des plus pauvres de nos sociétés
et influencer les prix de l'immobilier.
Cela ne l'empêche pas d'être positive
mais plus de personnes doivent en partager les avantages
et les reconnaître.
En 2002, l'ancien Secrétaire Général des Nations Unies, Kofi Annan,
a fait un discours à l'université de Yale
et le thème était la mondialisation inclusive.
C'est lors de ce discours qu'il a créé ce terme.
Il a dit, je paraphrase :
« La maison de verre qu'est la mondialisation
doit être ouverte à tous
si elle veut rester sûre.
La bigoterie et l'ignorance
sont les mauvais aspects de la mondialisation
sectaire et antagoniste. »
Cette idée de mondialisation inclusive a été brièvement ravivée en 2008
lors d'une conférence sur la gouvernance progressive
impliquant nombre de dirigeants des pays européens.
Mais entre l'austérité et la crise financière de 2008,
le concept a disparu sans laisser de trace.
La mondialisation a servi à soutenir des objectifs néolibéraux.
Elle est perçue comme faisant partie des plans d'une élite
plutôt que comme avantageuse pour tous.
Elle doit être reconquise sur des bases beaucoup plus inclusives
que celles d'aujourd'hui.
La question est : comment pouvons-nous atteindre cet objectif ?
Comment pouvons-nous trouver un équilibre entre la peur et l'aliénation d'un côté
et, d'un autre côté, le refus véhément
de s'abandonner à la xénophobie et au nationalisme ?
Cette question s'adresse à nous tous.
Je pense, en tant que spécialiste,
que les sciences sociales sont un point de départ.
Notre transformation doit viser à changer les idées et la matière,
et je veux vous donner quatre idées servant de point de départ.
La première est liée à la notion d'éducation civique.
Ce qui ressort du Brexit
est le fossé entre la perception du public et la réalité empirique.
Il a été suggéré que nous changions notre société post-factuelle,
où les preuves et la vérité n'importent plus
et où les mensonges ont le même statut que la clarté des preuves.
Comment pouvons-nous --
(Applaudissements)
Comment pouvons-nous reconstruire le respect de la vérité et des preuves
dans nos démocraties libérales ?
Cela doit commencer par l'éducation
mais aussi par la reconnaissance des énormes fossés qui existent.
En 2014, le sondeur Ipsos MORI
a publié une étude sur les avis concernant l'immigration
et elle montrait que le nombre d'immigrants augmentait,
donc l'inquiétude du public concernant l'immigration augmentait,
bien que cela ne révélait pas de causalité
puisque cela pouvait être lié, non pas aux chiffres,
mais au récit politique et médiatique qui les entourait.
La même étude a également révélé
une énorme désinformation du public
et une mauvaise compréhension de la nature de l'immigration.
Par exemple, les avis des Britanniques ont montré
que le public croyait que le nombre de demandeurs d'asile
était plus élevé que la réelle proportion d'immigration,
mais ils croyaient également que la migration scolaire
constituait une proportion bien moins élevée
que ce qu'elle représente.
Nous devons régler le problème de désinformation,
le fossé entre la perception et la réalité sur les points clés de la mondialisation.
Nous ne pouvons pas laisser nos écoles le faire seules,
bien qu'il soit important de commencer tôt.
Ce doit être une participation civique permanente
et un engagement du public encouragé par les sociétés.
La seconde chose qui, je crois, est une opportunité,
est l'idée d'encourager les interactions entre des communautés différentes.
(Applaudissements)
Une des choses qui, pour moi, ressort de façon remarquable
en regardant les avis des Britanniques sur l'immigration,
est que, ironiquement, les régions de mon pays
qui sont les plus tolérantes
sont celles qui ont les plus grands nombres d'immigrants.
Par exemple, Londres et le sud-est ont les plus grands nombres d'immigrants
et sont aussi, et de loin, les zones les plus tolérantes.
Ce sont les zones du pays ayant les niveaux d'immigration les plus bas
qui sont les plus sectaires et intolérantes envers les migrants.
Nous devons encourager les programmes d'échange.
Il faut s'assurer que les générations plus âgées, ne pouvant pas voyager,
aient accès à internet.
Il faut encourager, à des échelles locales et nationales,
plus de mouvement, plus de participation,
plus d'interaction avec des inconnus
dont les avis peuvent être contraires aux nôtres.
La troisième chose qui, à mon avis, est cruciale
et est fondamentale
est de nous assurer que tout le monde partage
les avantages de la mondialisation.
Cette illustration du Financial Times après le Brexit est frappante.
Elle montre tragiquement que ceux qui ont voté pour sortir de l'UE
étaient ceux qui, matériellement, bénéficiaient le plus
des échanges avec l'Union Européenne.
Mais le problème est que les gens dans ces endroits
ne se considéraient pas comme étant des bénéficiaires.
Ils ne croyaient pas qu'ils avaient vraiment accès
à des avantages matériels
liés au commerce et à la mobilité accrus à travers le monde.
Je travaille sur ces questions liées en majorité aux réfugiés,
et l'une des idées que j'ai beaucoup prêchée,
en particulier dans les pays en développement,
est que pour encourager l'intégration des réfugiés,
nous ne pouvons pas juste avantager les réfugiés,
nous devons traiter localement les inquiétudes des communautés hôtes.
En regardant cela,
une des politiques dominantes est de fournir
des services d'éducation et de santé disproportionnellement meilleurs,
un accès à des services sociaux
dans ces régions de forte immigration
afin d'apaiser les inquiétudes des populations locales.
Mais, en encourageant cela dans le monde en développement,
nous ne l'apportons pas chez nous
et ne l'appliquons pas à nos propres sociétés.
En outre, si nous prenons vraiment cela au sérieux,
il faut que les gens se partagent les avantages économiques,
nos entreprises et nos sociétés ont besoin d'un modèle de mondialisation
qui reconnaît qu'elles aussi doivent inclure les gens.
La quatrième et dernière idée que je veux mettre en avant
est l'idée selon laquelle nous avons besoin
de politiques plus responsables.
En sciences sociales, il y a, dans les faits,
très peu de comparaison des points de vue sur la mondialisation.
Mais, selon les études existantes,
à travers les différents pays et au cours de différentes périodes,
nous pouvons voir une forte variation
de point de vue et de tolérance
sur des questions telles que la migration et la mobilité d'un côté
et le libre-échange de l'autre.
Après un rapide coup d’œil aux données, une hypothèse qui émerge
est que les sociétés polarisées
sont bien moins tolérantes concernant la mondialisation.
Ce sont les sociétés telles que la Suède auparavant,
le Canada aujourd'hui,
où la politique est centriste,
où la droite et la gauche travaillent ensemble,
qui encouragent les points de vue positifs envers la mondialisation.
Ce que nous voyons aujourd'hui à travers le monde
c'est une polarisation tragique,
un échec dans le dialogue entre les extrêmes en politique
et un écart avec le terrain central libéral
qui encourage la communication et une compréhension commune.
Même si nous n'atteignons pas cela,
nous pouvons appeler nos politiques et nos médias
à oublier ce langage de peur et à être plus tolérants entre eux.
(Applaudissements)
Ce n'est qu'un essai,
en partie car cela doit être un projet inclusif et partagé.
Je suis toujours britannique.
Je suis toujours européen.
Je suis toujours un citoyen du monde.
Pour ceux d'entre nous qui croient
que nos identités ne s'excluent pas mutuellement,
nous devons travailler ensemble
pour assurer que la mondialisation emporte tout le monde avec nous
et ne laisse personne derrière.
Seulement à ce moment-là,
pourrons-nous réconcilier démocratie et mondialisation.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)